what of course it's fine to say you know
but she's not gonna move it because it's
defended oh she did it
we need a compilation chess.com social
media crew look through the podcast
games
[Music]
how many times I called the Moon
okay 11. you asked for it here we go
face on display so far don't know but he
has played a beautiful tricky game
yes it's been
back and forth action uh there's this
the thing is Jarvis can move the the
pawn
it's almost a Salesman knows what he's
doing he's gonna try to Andrea Andrea
there's a stalemate coming Pawn here
take King G4 he pushes and it's a
stalemate oh my goodness well you
clearly you I'm sure you taught Frank
about stalemate no okay
[Applause]
this I blame you for all of this this is
oh my goodness
oh God welcome to pod Champs ladies and
gentlemen
this is re this is real right this I
don't know if you're setting me up or
something I I genuinely can't tell I
think this is real
Bishop takes Pawn takes Queen takes
loses the bishop and if that happens I
will be heartbroken because you could
have just
your heart heavy
feeling okay
cart how is it you you can't even script
this stuff my man
defend the bishop again I just forgot
hey okay
do either one of these guys know
that these Bishops
and take each other like they they move
in that direction on the diagonals
dude okay okay he can't take he can't
take it because he can't take it because
she takes his Queen he's not gonna take
it he'll see that like the
I don't think so I think he plays too
fast I think he's gonna take it okay
with that or maybe he'll take F1 first
he's gonna take he's gonna take
something for sure
you go here and he comes here
Danny I don't want to be right man I
don't want to be right okay because she
doesn't see that the queen is hanging
she doesn't see that the queen is
hanging look I don't have time to get
down there as a queen no oh my God
yeah oh God right dude I do I just have
to I I don't know no oh no no
he's losing quick
oh my God
there we go oh my God oh my God
I'm focused maybe that'll make us play
better
good because white can go here and win
the queen
um if daily dose takes
he could get himself in trouble if he
takes okay there could be
a cheeky Fork it's a he's guaranteed to
win The Rook Annie all is on the board
because if this it's this and if this
it's this and if this he's gonna get
mated check Queen B2
foreign
commentator I really I I'm rooted for
both sides but it hurts to watch it
hurts to watch my student get
slaughtered like that and I knew he
added him I knew he would come back
never doubted once his position is is
hard to lose as long as it stays how it
is
yeah for sure
unless he starts going totally crazy
with something like Ponte G
I can confirm you weren't cheating there
was no you had no you had no board that
they couldn't see
wow you did you couldn't even complete
the sentence no no no no no that's uh
that that was one of my more legendary
calls I think uh that was wild these
these players kind of like I I kind of
understand that a lot of their brains
it's probably why I got to 4 million
subscribers for like intermediates right
but I I just understand his style and
his style is like I should push here but
there's no King here so I'm gonna push
here but as you get better you just go
like I'm throwing punches where I'm not
stronger I should not be bullying my
opponent on this side of the board oh my
goodness but but and I'm telling you
this game is not over because no no to
win this white needs to bring the king
like to these squares oh
as long as he's making E3 like like oh
yeah like this is not over Anna this is
not over King here is not over King here
take here always lost
this is back to winning
the only chance Anna the only chance
King B3 Rook F3 and somehow he hangs his
pawns unbelievable I called it two see
two come on here we go it's gonna be a
queen it's queening
just don't go anyone is a queen yeah D1
is a queen that's it oh God
yeah like he could go H3 and he's losing
you know like uh no obviously I'm with
you um and if black could somehow Drive
the H Pawn maybe that works out but
overall I'm with you I I this is
fascinating
oh he played it you called it oh my God
you you crystal ball gazing you know
commentating you know what and you you
just jinxed him you just did the
commentator's curse
listen I love daily dose like I love his
videos uh and uh and he's also like a
super nice guy you know if I was more in
La I'd consider him a friend but my God
if I have to hold him by that hoodie and
scream at him to slow the F down I mean
it Danny it's the same square where he
made a fatal mistake against sap that he
played H3 boom it's the same thing he
played H3 hung the G3 Pawn this time oh
my goodness
thank you
[Music]